[Music]
on this Saturday night Canadian
emergency Wards on life support
staff shortages caused some Ontario
hospitals to close their doors to be
brutally honest what can you do a system
in need of urgent care with no help on
the way
conditions conspire for wildfires
currently the fire danger in the
province is very high in evacuations in
BC Alberta on edge but weather is just
part of the problem in Kentucky dozens
killed by flooding I thought I'm gonna
have to swim and the toll is rising with
the water
and almost a stop over here just another
day at the office the danger level is
real for a Canadian born to do the
unimaginable in the air
well-national with far Nasser reporting
tonight Colleen Christie
good evening thanks for joining us
getting critically ill or injured could
be a very scary Prospect in many parts
of Canada right now emergency rooms are
in crisis right across the country in
Ontario Staffing shortages mean some
Hospital departments have been forced to
close and patients are waiting more than
20 hours to be treated Frontline staff
namely nurses are overwhelmed and are
now begging the government for help but
as microlay reports the problem has no
short-term Solutions
mere days into a province-wide
assessment of the Health Care System the
Ontario Nurses Association visited a
neonatal unit they have 51 babies and 18
nurses on a shift and then at Children's
ER they're set up for about 60 visits a
day they're having 120 plus visits a day
how does that work the system as
Catherine Hoy sees it needs Urgent Care
the Ontario Hospital Association pegs
the job vacancy rate for registered
nurses at 13 percent hoi's early
assessment suggests it's far worse we
will be well over 20. I hope we're not
at 30 percent the shortage predates the
pandemic but it's become more acute as
nurses have either quit or retired I
personally don't know what we could do
tomorrow that would make a difference
and and that's the that's the
frustrating part of all of this is we
all know that the problem is there but
how do you fit how do you fix it
Ontario's Ministry of Health would not
speak on camera sending a statement that
reads we have an ambitious plan for the
largest Health Care Recruitment and
training initiative in the province's
history with a plan to add over 5 000
new and upskilled registered nurses what
they don't say is where they'll find
them to be brutally honest what can you
do I mean we can't clone nurses I wish
we could one option is to Fast Track the
hiring of more ien's or internationally
educated nurses who have to meet
standards set by the College of nurses
before joining the workforce even for
nurses like Rola L mubar who arrived in
Canada with years of experience and a
master's degree it took me two years to
become registered in Ontario in addition
to nursing she now helps other iens
through a group called care which
currently has 900 nurses in the pipeline
however they believe far more have
chosen to walk away from the profession
rather than go through years of
certification there might be other
nurses out there aliens that working as
as flourished as as Tim Horton that we
don't know about them they didn't they
dropped even the idea of starting the
process to become registered hiring more
nurses is not the solution to the Health
Care crisis but it's a good start
microwave Global News Toronto
with Vancouver Pratt underway Health
officials have set up monkeypox
vaccination clinics and now officials in
Montreal are worried some big tourist
events May soon cause a spike in cases
it comes one week after the disease was
officially declared a public health
emergency by the World Health
Organization as Dan Spector reports the
concerns come as both the distribution
and efficacy of the vaccine faces
questions
foreign
next week Montreal's pride festival will
be back in full swing for the first time
since 2019 bringing joy and celebration
to the city but with monkey pox still
circulating a doctor on the front line
of the outbreak is concerned uh we're
worried
Thomas says his Clinic just saw its
100th monkey pox patient he wants to put
up the message that though the disease
is not fatal that doesn't mean it's
benign he's seeing people with severe
pain it's painful it's it's a big like
that on the genitals it's sir on one of
my Pearson all in the face
359 of Canada's 803 confirmed cases are
in Quebec infections are also rising in
the United States now with more than 4
900 cases the bulk of them are in New
York state which has more than 1200
probable or confirmed cases we think
that there might be
um cases related to travel uh over the
coming weeks monkeypox is still mostly
affecting men who have sex with other
men and is transmitted by prolonged
skin-to-skin contact there is a vaccine
and about 27 000 doses have been
administered across the country
including more than a thousand in
Montreal but Tomas says it's not enough
I'm surprised how many might be since
I've not been vaccinated or who are high
risk patients any man who has sex with
other male Partners outside of a stable
unique partner are eligible in Montreal
for those who are getting the shot Tomah
wonders how well it's working there are
very few data of the efficacy of this
vaccine and it's only one dose it's
supposed to be a two dose vaccine but so
far only single doses have been offered
we have a large population that would
benefit from the vaccine and limited
supplies officials want to encourage
every eligible person to go get the shot
Montreal pride has been working to
promote it too the inspector Global News
Montreal
soaring temperatures in western Canada
have sparked dozens of new wildfires in
BC and put albertans on edge one of the
largest wildfires is in BC's Okanagan
region where nearly two dozen properties
are under an evacuation order and two
dozen more on standby the fire broke out
early Friday and quickly grew to 100
hectares Alberta hasn't seen any major
wildfires yet but firefighters there are
prepared to deploy at a moment's notice
experts say while a wet spring has
helped there's still a serious risk
Tracy nagai has more
this pounding rain scene in and around
Calgary earlier this year and the
humidity levels are now being credited
for keeping wildfires in the area at a
minimum so far this summer we're not
seeing the critically low humidities yet
which we can see at this time of year
which will really impact our Wildfire
operations however experts say the
moisture from days past can only compete
with these extreme temperatures for so
long we are under a fire advisory that
was enacted this week the implications
of data we're no longer issuing any
types of fire permits and it also serves
as a warning to our recreational users
to be extra diligent this long weekend
and parts of the province continue to be
listed as high or very high for Wildfire
danger currently the fire danger in the
province is very high in the southern
areas low to moderate in the Northern
areas in the province NBC record
temperatures and an extended dry spell
have fire Crews on high alert it's
really accelerated the drying of our
forest fuels and conditions we've also
seen the snow at upper elevations
finally leave so the forests are now
more receptive to ignitions and more
available to burn the big concerns
remain around thunderstorms and human
activity we don't want people burning
outside of a proof fire pits we don't
want people using fireworks as much fun
as they are
fireworks can set off
you know multiple fires and before
you even call 9-1-1 it's a raging
Inferno last year 67 percent of our
wildfires were human caused so we
encourage anyone who's out in the
forested area to use caution Wildfire
officials say during the long weekend
they'll often find dozens of campfires
still smoldering and with several weeks
of Summer still left they're not letting
their guard down anytime soon
tracing a guy Global News
the death toll in Kentucky is rising
with flash floods killing more than two
dozen people so far the governor expects
the number to rise significantly but
says it could take weeks to find all of
the victims rescue crews are struggling
to get into the hardest hit areas and as
Jennifer Johnson reports more rain is on
the way
the devastation in Eastern Kentucky is
massive with some waterways still
cresting and more rain in the forecast
for Sunday and Monday search Crews
continue to rescue people trapped in
their homes but other places are still
too difficult to reach either by air or
on the ground
at least 28 state roads remain blocked
by water or mudslides First Responders
have already saved hundreds of lives
including Patricia Colombo trapped in
her car by raging flood waters I thought
I'm gonna have to swim and I didn't know
what to do honestly I didn't in an area
used to flooding this was something
never seen before now the focus is on
finding the missing mountains of debris
have been swept Downstream where
officials hope some survivors may be
found our goal today is to get as many
people to safety as possible and make a
plan for Sunday afternoon through Monday
when the storms leave children are among
the dead including four siblings one
local sheriff recorded his first
fatality his great aunt I sat down in my
hallway last night about 12 30 and I
cried for an hour with so many
unaccounted for the death toll is
expected to rise 72 year old Dennis
Stacey is among the missing his home was
completely flooded there is no cell
service in most of the region Stacy's
daughter is waiting in agony it's just
that not knowing and the fact that he's
missing uh it's just
excruciating President Joe Biden has
declared the region a disaster area
pledging billions to rebuild never in my
life we've seen a co-op that fast those
who were lucky to survive the fast
rising Waters Now find themselves with
either no home many just floated away or
very little left the mud's got to be
squidges out get it all cleaned up you
got a Clorox disinfect everything
officials say it will take years to
rebuild the area among the poorest
regions in America and it will likely
take weeks before all of the missing are
accounted for
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
following the conclusion of what he
called a week-long penitential
pilgrimage in Canada Pope Francis agreed
the abuses indigenous people faced while
attending residential schools amounted
to a cultural genocide
the part of made the comments to
reporters on his flight back to Rome
from the kaluit he says he didn't use
the term during his Canadian trip
because it never came to mind but when
asked about it he stressed that what he
described in a number of the apologies
he delivered during the trip was clearly
a genocide
residential school survivors and their
families looking for help can call the
residential school survivors and
families Crisis Line the number is
1-800-721-0066
more than 120 people were injured in the
Iraqi capital of Baghdad today after
thousands of protesters breached the
country's Parliament
[Applause]
the supporters of an influential Shia
cleric stormed the high security
building for the second time in a week
as they opposed the nomination of a
pro-iran rival candidate for prime
minister the large crowds pushed past
security forces in baghdad's heavily
fortified green zone in order to get in
coming up Donald Trump why he may be
ramping up to another run
U.S President Joe Biden is heading back
into quarantine after testing positive
for covid-19 again Biden tested positive
for the first time nine days ago and
tested negative four days ago officials
say the 79 year old has a rare case of
coveted rebound following treatment with
an antiviral drug paxilavid the White
House says Biden is asymptomatic but
will isolate for at least another five
days
still hurting from his 2020 election
loss and facing potential prosecution
for his role in the January 6th
Insurrection there are signs former U.S
president Donald Trump is preparing to
make another run at the White House the
former president may even launch his
campaign before this November's critical
midterm elections Jackson prosco reports
the first time since leaving the White
House Donald Trump returned to
Washington this week teasing his future
plans but they really want to damage me
so I can no longer
go back to work for you
and I don't think that's going to happen
the former president remains obsessed
with his election loss still pushing his
big election lie it was a catastrophe
that election a disgrace to our country
yet all signs point to Trump running
again in 2024 a campaign in which he is
likely to play the victim and in 2024
most importantly we are going to take
back our beautiful
magnificent White House
avoiding prosecution may be Trump's
biggest motivation the Department of
Justice is still probing his role in the
attempt to overthrow the 2020 election
State officials in Georgia are deepening
their investigation too and he certainly
will portray any indictment as political
extremely political if it happens while
he is a presidential candidate he likely
won't go unchallenged former vice
president Mike Pence who barely escaped
the mob on January 6th is now testing
the waters with a message about moving
beyond the election lie now some people
may choose to focus on the past
but elections are about the future
and I believe conservatives must focus
on the future to win back America
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis is quickly
trying to make a name for himself As
Trump without the baggage I am not
backing down one inch and we are going
to make sure we stand up to the left
when might Trump make his return
official only he knows that but if it's
before November 8th the former president
could become the key issue in
high-stakes midterm elections because
he's simply going to interfere with the
process and become an issue potentially
even bigger than Biden and inflation
as political comebacks go this is no
sure bet but Trump has made it clear
he's not ready to fade away from public
life
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
I had the impact of Rapid Glacier melts
on water supplies and sea levels
you're watching global national
[Music]
just like last summer in western Canada
this year has seen extreme temperatures
in Europe and elsewhere in the northern
hemisphere the effects are perhaps most
notable at high altitude and latitude on
glaciers and ice sheets as Redmond
Shannon reports the acceleration of
their Retreat is having an immediate and
long-term impact
it's high summer on top of the arctic's
largest block of ice the enormous two
kilometer deep Greenland ice sheet
scientists are literally trying to get
to the bottom of it drilling down to
better understand the sheets past and
its future as it continues to shrink in
a warming planet we suspect that there
is melt water at the Bedrock and that's
why the ice can move that fast in an ice
stream but that is something we will
only know when we get to the pet rock
this summer has seen the temperature
Spike to almost zero high up on the
sheet researchers say a widespread
melting event across the sheet happened
just once in the last Millennium but
four times since the year 2000. if
you're close to Melting the ice get
really sticky and the the skis they
stick and also the the airplanes they
actually break up the skiway so it's
it's really hard to do landing and
takeoff
but more importantly a melting ice sheet
in Greenland means rising sea levels
worldwide
thousands of kilometers away in the Alps
Swiss glaciologists Andreas linsbauer
has never seen anything like this year
before 2022 the deepest drop in ice
level he'd seen was one meter
called Midway
tourists don't even need to measure the
difference you don't
it always in nature the consequences and
now you really see it like oh my God I
was here like 50 50s ago and now the
snow is gone and the
the rivers in the mountains are not
there anymore it's a similar story in
western Canada where scientists say 70
percent of glaciers will be gone by the
end of the century with huge potential
consequences for fresh water supplies
the record Summer of 2021 only
accelerated their retreat
in Switzerland this hiker says he won't
be around to see the long-term effects
but says he's worried for what these
melts will mean for his grandchildren
Redmond Shannon Global News London
a thrill a second job for a Canadian Air
race pilot next
on our costume are we going down the
road and we celebrate
life once again being celebrated on the
streets of Toronto today as the
Caribbean Carnival parade made its Grand
return after two years of pandemic
cancellations the 55th anniversary of
the parade was one of the biggest to
date with an estimated 10 000 people
participating and even more taking part
in the festivities
in British Columbia thousands are
expected to flood Vancouver's iconic
English Bay for the final night of the
celebration of light the annual
fireworks spectacle also took a pandemic
Hiatus but it's back and with an
aerobatic show as Jay janauer found out
the pilot was born for the job
thinking straight up
almost a stop over here
my office uh it's a fast one faster than
most very exciting and it is I think
truly it's that three-dimensional
Freedom where you're just not
constrained really in any way shape or
form of what you can do with the
airplane being in the cockpit with Red
Bull aerobatic pilot Pete MacLeod is
more thrilling than any Thrill Ride you
can think of and not throw a minute kind
of stuff more like thrill a second
[Music]
all these Maneuvers
um I've done thousands of times
um at a higher altitude and you bring
that Precision in to be able to do it
low level because when you are doing it
close to the ground
um there's zero margin for air there's
no lying about that it's it the danger
level is real it's very pass fail ready
for my cloud you're cleared into the
track smoke on
Pete's one of Red Bull's top Air race
Pilots his first seat time in a plane
coming at the age of six weeks old when
his father who was a pilot took Pete for
his first ride he's been flying ever
since but not for the reason you're
probably thinking of it's interesting
you know I I've never labeled myself as
like a stunt man or an adrenaline junkie
actually I'm not
um he won't catch me like hopping on a
skateboard McLeod's flown as Red Bull
stunt plane all over the world but
performing here above English Bay in
front of hundreds of thousands of fellow
Canadians is Pete's definition of a
perfect work day and what a day at the
office it is the the event here in
Vancouver is something we look forward
to the desk is the same the layout of
the desk and the plane but the view out
the office window changes so I've been
very fortunate to fly and compete um
largely all over the world and which is
pretty cool from a kid from Northern
Ontario here we go
hahaha
[Applause]
my job uh my job's not a job I go out
and do what I love and have fun every
day and I'm just Ultra fortunate that uh
that it works and people enjoy it so I I
think that's the main thing for me Jay
janor Global Sports
amazing and just a little scary that's
global national for this Saturday night
I'm Colleen Christie tonight's your
Canada is Vernon Yacht Club in Vernon
British Columbia thanks for watching
hope you'll join us again tomorrow good
night
foreign
[Music]